podría convertirse en la primera
afroamericana en ocupar el puesto más
alto de la justicia estadounidense
cantando y brawn jackson brindó su
discurso frente al senado en fort
benning ser inferior gracias por
convocar esta audiencia y por considerar
mi nominación a la corte suprema de los
estados unidos me siento honrada de
estar aquí
hanvon en enero tve en febrero el
presidente joe biden y su historia
postulando el mandatario demócrata
durante su campaña prometió diversificar
el tribunal que durante dos siglos
estuvo conformado por hombres blancos
los senadores compartieron sus elogios y
preocupaciones mons
sólo ha habido 115 jueces en la historia
de nuestra nación la nominación de la
jueza jackson por supuesto es histórica
lo que me preocupa y soy muy sincero
es que en todos los casos en cada uno de
estos 7 la jueza jackson dictó una
sentencia indulgente que estaba por
debajo de lo que recomendaban las normas
federales y los fiscales
jackson de 53 años fue nombrada miembro
del tribunal federal por el entonces
presidente para en el 2013 su nombre fue
noticia también en el año 2019 cuando
ordenó al ex abogado de la casa blanca
durante la presidencia del trump
testificar ante el comité judicial de la
cámara sobre si trump había obstruido la
investigación del ex fiscal bühler sobre
la interferencia rusa en las elecciones
del 2016 las audiencias durarán cuatro
días y allí se decidirá si eeuu las
historias reivindicando a una minoría
del país como son los afroamericanos que
han venido históricamente denunciando
las vulneraciones de sus derechos